i see the results of [ __ ] you know
there's a lot of it down here no yeah
a lot of people are [ __ ] all day
that's all they do
so tell me about tell me about the the
gang
pass you have
um i remember when the child molester
hit the yeller then um
i was a new guy he was in prison yeah
they gave me a knife and told me to go
deal with them
they told me to figure it out and this
is uh
which gang were you is it aryan
brotherhood i was associated with him
because of my uncle aryan brotherhood so
i didn't really have a choice
you know all's he do is kill people they
clean the yard up
and cops
landed a child molester on the yard on
purpose
just so they could lock us down
because they got tired of us making them
do paperwork you know my cell came up i
was scared to death
because if i got caught it was a life
sentence
and i got caught anyway
i turned a 16 and a half sentence into
20 years with 85 percent
i'm lucky i just got dead i could have
got life you know
how many years are you doing prison i
did 20 years straight three years
straight
my my celly had three life sentences
without
he was driving around with a head with
somebody's head
you know in his car yeah i was always
there with real killers you know i
didn't play at all you know
um
but you were involved in that life even
before prison
a little bit when i was a kid
when my uncle was out and these people
were out you know
i was forced to do a lot of stuff
i was pretty much forced to be a
skinhead you know
and what kind of what kind of
a lot of drug dealings a lot of violence
you know
is it racially based racially based
against the jews really is that right
you know the kids got it against the
blacks it's not against the blacks or
it's against the religion you know
religion and the government you know
it's those that rule over us you know
all these rules they have for us you
know
now i look at us if i were to abide it
by the rules i wouldn't have done all
the time i've done you know yeah you see
you see things differently now now i see
things a lot differently that i'm older
you know i don't want to go back you
know
all you see on the yard is violence when
the yard opens it closes you know
somebody's getting stabbed
a lot of it over drugs drug debts
now it's not you don't really have much
of a time to laugh in there
that's real serious now
i live my life now seriously you know
are there things you've done in your
past that you
take to bed with you every night
i have nightmares about the first person
i stabbed you know
then i find out he wasn't even a child
molester the paperwork was wrong man
they read it wrong somebody read the
paperwork on the wrong there's a rest
report
it was
the the girl the kid there wasn't even a
kid she was over 18 you know
and it was consensual it wasn't it's not
like she refused it
you know
it's like a big mistake i still have
nightmares about it huh
yeah that resulted in the murder yeah it
was a lot of blood
person died i could have got life you
know
no
i was pretty much made they were always
going to do it or they was going to do
me you know
you don't have a choice you know
i feel sorry for people to hit level
fours you know
general pop you're going to have to
you're the new person you've got to
you know
that's
rough life there
you know
you can turn a
date into a no date
quick
yeah i'm sure you had friends that were
just
in prison until death right now
i don't want to go back you know
you've been out for how long now
you've been out for how long now i've
been out for almost eight years you know
i think i've been in handcuffs for maybe
five minutes
you know
that's because of my tattoos they still
haunt me
now you had you had some serious tattoos
on your face right i used to have cereal
more
a lot of political swazis lightning
bolts the swastika was where i had them
on my cheeks
you know i had to get it took off it
looked stupid for one
it looked dumb you know
looks like a it's like come arrest me
i would have been stopped every i used
to get stopped at every corner you know
i couldn't go to like beverly hills or
anything they wouldn't even let me in
the stores
oh no you can't come in here
can't eat here you can't come in here
never tried to take my knees to school
and snatch my niece away from me what
are you doing with this guy who are you
they they call my family and see who i
was if i was really their uncle and it's
embarrassing man you know
it's like a public embarrassment
like a circus freak or something you
know
sometimes the area i live in they still
look at me like that like yeah
they look at me like a like a monster
like
just see that looks like it
like what the hell i have to look in the
mirror myself sometimes i do look kind
of crazy you know
you've come a long way though sounds
like a long way my attitude used to be
really bad you know
i was institutionalized for a long time
now i see the police i avoid them
people are going to make judgments on
you just because i don't have no parole
or nothing so no warrants or nothing so
but just based on how you look this is
based on how i look they stereotype you
they judge you you know
a lot of people don't realize that
you get stereotyped for what other
people do and it's gonna be for the rest
of your life you know
what about getting the other tattoos
around i'm gonna get some more removed
you know
off my hands on my face
slowly that stuff hurts it's painful
you can smell your skin burn
there is no pain like getting tattoo
removal
you can smell your skin burn like i can
set you up there's somebody else i'm
helping who uh
has the same problem she doesn't want to
get her tattoos removed because it's
just too painful so yeah
it hurts too bad i called about 25
dermatologists and found somebody who
will numb you up like a dentist does
when you yeah they'll tell you it's
going to hurt really bad
yeah it brings tears into your allergy
yeah you'll be numbed up 100 percent
yeah you won't feel the thing
it just takes a long time you've got to
go in sessions yeah like three
treatments i think now but to is this
the happiest moment in your life right
now probably yeah your freedom now makes
you
i haven't been so happy i didn't know
what being happy meant you know
i was always depressed
you got to wake up to look at the same
bars again and the same dude
he's never getting out so you know
misery loves company so
they're thinking about missions they can
send you on you know
they don't want you to get out because
they're not getting out they need
somebody to talk to
and he didn't have much to talk about
you know
i heard the same story over and over
about how we drove around with
somebody's head
to prove that he killed the person
no it's [ __ ] ridiculous you know
it's the same story you hear over and
over from different people
what do you think the base the the core
of all that behavior is is it is it just
the
having parents that were monsters or is
it probably you know my environment
product my environment you know
so all i see was violence people getting
beat up
from weapons weapon moving people moving
weapons around drugs being moved by
pounds
a bunch of idiots you
know a lot of them are trying to get out
of it too you can't get out of it once
you're in it you know
i just got away from it
you know
got tired of it you know
i don't want to spend the rest of my
life in prison for somebody else you
know
they don't send no money on your books
they don't come visit you you know
you're on your own
with nothing
no date no
no hopes nothing they're all going
judge takes all that away from you
when i went to when i got busted i lost
my house and everything i paroled
homeless you know
with a sweatsuit and a piece of
cardboard i slept in the alley
i got tired of that now i got an
apartment i'm cool and all that [ __ ] you
know
try to tell these kids over by macarthur
park man they're
they're just robbing merchandise every
day
they just want to stay on the street
that [ __ ] ain't cool it's cold out there
you know
it's freezing
what do you think the solution is
to this problem because it's go ongoing
today
still goes on today that fell in all
the drugs
but but that that behavior the drug
the drug use comes from probably
something in their childhood yeah their
childhood yeah they're numbing something
that happened earlier they're depressed
they just want something to suppress it
you know yeah they don't want to think
about it self-medication then it becomes
an addiction you know
then they have to have it
they'll do anything they go to the to
the desk to do anything for it and they
don't they don't care
you know
i try to keep them away from me
you know because
all the stuff i have i'm not
i'm not gonna let them steal it you know
i'm not gonna lose my freedom for nobody
you know
not much of a substitute for loving
parents is there now
a lot of them ran away from home you
know their kids
come to the wrong area you know
tell me about your parents again i
didn't have one you know my dad was at
ha my mom was
was pretty much underneath him you know
your dad was a hell's angel no
he's dead now you know they killed the
police killed him
he got killed over vietnam in kentucky
going interstate dropping off weapons
that killed him
because he couldn't get busted you know
he had too much
several life sentences he was carrying
i pretty much raised myself you know
i didn't do a very good job i didn't
know what
what regular people regular life was you
know
are you learning now yeah
how old are you i'm 53 53. it's almost
kind of late you know it's never too
late no never too late i still still
people that are higher you know it's
still work you know it's still funny to
learn huh there's still plenty to learn
yeah i'm still willing to learn you know
it keeps you young i think yeah you just
keep learning now it keeps you young
when you start thinking you know
everything is when you start to laugh
there's people know way more than i do
man
you know yeah your attitude is very
positive now which is really nice to see
you you wouldn't suspect somebody like
you would have
the
appetite for learning and the insight
and the the ability to understand things
like i try to keep myself positive you
know
do it all you know it's not really not
that bad those people got a lot of words
you know
i got an apartment i could be doing a
lot worse now
you're healthy yeah
i'm walking down the street there's some
people living bad
a lot of them choose to live like that
though i don't yeah you're staying out
of trouble
yeah
i try to
not perfect but i'm not out there trying
to break the law all day you know
i try to stay out the way now you know
try to keep myself busy doing something
you know yeah it's nice to see somebody
change yeah you're making some really
significant changes this shit's rough
you know
is it scary huh is it scary to be
changing like this
yeah sometimes it is it's uncomfortable
yeah
it was uncomfortable for a while
it gets uncomfortable and not as bad as
it used to be you know
i was out of my comfort zone now right
that's a good thing my comfort zone was
not going good though
it's not a good comfort zone to have
it's getting worse you know
they're passing out a lot of time
this coronavirus shit's lifted people in
for a surprise
what are you afraid of now
going back to jail now you know
for somebody else
you know
for a woman or something
got a weak spot for him you know i'll
fall in their little traps you know join
the club huh join the club
yeah there's a lot of us yeah
they're good at it you know
where do you see yourself in five years
where would you like to see yourself in
five years
the house you know
a little more insight on things you know
a little more patience
patience gets thin you know
gotta have a lot of patience nowadays
not a lot of stuffed open like it used
to be you know
i want you to put in more work
you gotta have a lot of patience
it's rough you know yeah you're learning
some some great lessons right yeah
got to be on the bus a lot you got to
move around a lot you know
i think stuff requires a lot of money
ain't got no money i feel sorry for it
it's rough out there man
it can't be lazy you know
try to kind of keep a positive attitude
you know i mean
you're doing it
yeah
do it all you got to try to keep your
head up you know sometimes it's hard you
know
my head's not always up but i end up
keeping it up you know
at the end of the day all that really
don't matter anyway you know
it's about yourself you know
got to worry about yourself sometimes
not everybody else you know
i worry about a lot of other people but
myself you know i got to worry about
myself you know yeah if you take care of
yourself you'll be able to take care of
others now you can't you don't care
about yourself you know that's what it
is we stop caring about ourselves you
just give up you know it's not that
serious you know
it's places that'll help you
you can get help you know
just gotta go do it have you done
therapy or anything like that i've done
a little bit you know
when i was in yeah
at the end you know
some of it was a lot of it was just a
lot of book [ __ ] you know
the people that were teaching it had no
idea what we were going through it's a
lot of book stuff you know
what do you find has helped you the most
because you've definitely made a turn in
your life
a lot of the stuff the 12-step stuff you
know a lot of it does apply you know
yeah yeah i think that applies to
everybody's life first of all admit
we're an addict you know a lot of us
don't you know
you know i still do drugs but not like i
used to you know yeah there's a lot of
different types of addictions yeah
yeah a lot of money could be won
anything could be one new in my view
lack of courage and laziness are
addictions yeah
everything's a lot of it turns into an
addiction
we lust after a lot of stuff you know
it's rough you know
because life
boils down to his life you got to deal
with it you know
stop doing stuff you know stop doing
stuff that's gonna get you arrested you
know
or stick to misdemeanors everybody wants
to do them felonies
and get on gr or some do something you
know
a lot of people are looking for an easy
way out i i've learned yeah but it might
be your last way out you know
turned into a life sentence quick you
know
they're passing out life now you know
they're not playing you
i got two stripes so i can't do none of
that no more
i can't do it no more
i'm cool with the gangs and all that
[ __ ] now i'm cold too old you know
it's too old for it all
i've got time for it you know
all right man
thank you so much man yeah great seeing
you again
people like these
you